by wednesday at 4 p.m eastern we'll know
whether or not the franchise tag players
have long-term contracts there's also a
transition tag player kenyon drake for
the cardinals
dak press got the big name here no
indication that he and the cowboys are
working their way toward a final
contract remember the cowboys have to
offer him something that gets him to
give up 69.08 million over the next two
years plus that year three who knows
what the cowboys would do 45 million
under the transition tag 54 million
under the franchise tag or let him walk
away and let him hit the market yeah
if we're not sure what the guy's value
really is let him hit the market
you find out what his value is
maybe you find out the hard way because
somebody else pays him more than you
will
but that may be what happens in 2022
either way
cowboys have to give him something
that will convince him to give up his
right to just say i'm going year to year
i'll take my 31.4 million this year i'll
take my 37.68 million next year
and then year three we'll see what
happens
we laid out the numbers last week he's
in a better spot over the next few years
than patrick mahomes is other than the
140 million dollar injury guarantee that
mahomes got under his contract but again
you can go out and buy that insurance
and dak prescott surely has
he's in a great position from a cash
flow standpoint flexibility standpoint
and ultimately ability to become a free
agent by 2023 when mahomes will still
have nine years left under contract with
the kansas city chiefs one last point
about franchise tags
there's a few players who still haven't
signed their tender aj green yannick and
gawkway chris jones
i wonder if the teams are thinking at
all about rescinding the tender
because at this point
who else is going to pay these guys
what they are due to make under the
franchise tag who else is going to give
these guys what they want by way of a
long-term deal right now
i mean maybe chris jones
right maybe somebody says we'll bite the
bullet over the short term to get a
dominant defensive lineman who
potentially could be one of the best
defensive linemen and all of football
will do that
but
think about the bengal situation
they typically don't keep guys who are
franchise tagged beyond their franchise
tag year if this is aj green's last year
in cincinnati or if they may trade him
halfway through the season and they're
looking at the balance sheets and they
realize they're going to lose a ton of
money if you can clear up whatever the
number is 17 million dollars if you can
just make that go away
just by saying oh go ahead aj go be a
free agent first of all good for the
bengals second of all
is aj green gonna get that money from
someone else at this point is he really
gonna get that kind of money
so just something to think about is this
deadline looms if these guys don't do
long-term deals will teams for the
players who haven't accepted their
franchise tenders
consider rescinding to tender it's
happened three times in the last 20
years jeremiah trotter
corey simon and josh norman
uh i wouldn't rule it out this year
um given the the realities of the
pandemic
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports